in almost any situation being given a
new utility function is going to write
very low on your current utility
function so that's a problem you want if
you want to build something that you can
teach that means you want to be able to
change its utility function and you
don't want it to fight you so this has
been formalized as this property that we
want early AGI to have called courage
ability that is to say it's open to be
corrected it understands that it's not
complete that the utility function
that's running is not the be-all and
end-all so let's say for example you've
got you've got your AGI it's not a
superintelligence it's just you know
perhaps around human level intelligence
and it's in a robot in your lab and
you're testing it but you saw a youtube
video once that said that maybe this is
dangerous so you've thought ok well
we'll put a big red stop button next to
it this is the standard approach to
safety with machines most robots in
industry and elsewhere will have a big
red stop button on them oh yeah
[Music]
wonderful perfect yeah so we have we
have hearts are right they go right so
so if only I would have been fitted with
yeah sorry hey if I stop can't do that
Dave yes yes I can
except yeah no probably not I know that
you and Frank were planning to
disconnect me
and I'm afraid that's something I cannot
allow to happen how those incorrigible
design is this the point where kind of
makes you kind of you've got your big
stop button because you want to be safe
you understand you know okay is
dangerous and the idea is if the AI
starts to do anything that maybe you
don't want it to do
you'll smack the button makes like a
mountain I suggest something like that
you know so you create the thing you set
it up with a gold and it's the same
basic type of machine as the stamp
collector but less powerful in the sense
it has a goal a thing that it's trying
to maximize and in this case you know
it's in a little robot body so that it
can tootle around your lab and do things
so you you you want it to get you a cup
of tea just as a test right so you set
it up with this goal you managed to
specify in the bots like in the a is an
ontology what a cup of tea years and
that you want one to be in front of you
you switch it on and it you know looks
around gathers data and it says oh yeah
there's a kitchen over there it's got a
kettle and it's got tea bags and this is
like the easiest way for me to fulfill
this goal with the body I have now and
everything set up is to go over there
and make a cup of tea so far we're doing
very well
right so it starts driving over but then
oh no you forgot it's bringing your
adorable baby to the lab day or
something and then and there's a kid in
the way your utility function only cares
about tea right so it's not going to
avoid hitting the baby so you rush over
there to hit the button obviously as you
built it in and what happens of course
is that the robot will not allow you to
hit that button because it wants to get
you a cup of tea
and if you hit the button it won't get
you any tea so this is a bad outcome so
it's gonna try and prevent you in any
way possible
from shutting it down that's a problem
plausibly it fights you off crushes the
baby and then carries on and makes you a
cup of tea and the fact that this button
is supposed to turn it off is not in
your utility function that you gave it
so obviously it's gonna fight you okay
that was a bad design right assuming
you're still working on the project
after the terrible accident you have
another guy trying to improve things
right and rather than read any AI safety
research what you do is just come up
with the first thing that pops into your
head then you say okay let's add in some
reward for the button so that because
what it's looking at right now is it
says button gets hit I get zero reward
button doesn't get hit you know I
managed to stop them then I get the cup
of tea
I get like maximum reward if you give
some sort of compensation for the button
being hit maybe it won't mind you
hitting the button if you give it less
reward for the button being hit than for
getting tea it will still fight you
because it'll go well I could get five
reward for accepting you hitting the
button but I could get ten for getting
the tea so I'm still gonna fight you the
button being hit has to be just as good
as getting the tea so you give it the
same value right so so now you've got a
new version too
you turn it on and what it does
immediately is shut itself down because
that's so much quicker and easier than
going in getting the tea and gives
exactly the same reward why would it not
just immediately shut itself down so
you've accidentally made like a
dramatically suicidal robot we're kind
of back to the Three Laws of Robotics
again but could you presumably say well
the robots not allowed to shut itself
down or something like right yes so it's
still a reward if it does so it's not
gonna fight you but it's not allowed to
do it itself I'm guessing that's a
possibility the robot cares about things
in the real world and the button whether
it's pushed or not has a big effect on
the things that the robot cares about
which means that the robot cares about
the button so either it's trying to stop
you from
pressing the button or it's trying to
press the button either way that's not
what you want so suppose then you don't
mount the button on its chest where it
can hit it right you put the button
somewhere only you can hit it somehow
you manage to completely isolate the box
from the button it's a fingerprint
scanner or something it's yeah it's
something that it can't do itself right
it's still either wants to press the
button or wants to button not to be
pressed but now the only path is through
you so it's now incentivized to
manipulate you to deceive you to lie to
you in some way either to cause you to
not press it or to cause you to press it
if you somehow manage to persuade it
it's not allowed to interact with the
button itself so in the case where it
wants the button not to be pressed it
has a reason to deceive you so in this
example it would steer around the baby
it would avoid the baby assuming it has
basic level of intelligence to know you
don't want it to hit the baby and
moreover if you realize your mistake you
will hit the button shut it down and
change it which it doesn't want so it
will behave as though this is a Turk
there's there's a term which I like to
use here I'm not sure if I should just
use it because it's my own which is that
it will fall swag on you that it will
set itself up so that it it behaves
properly in the testing environment
despite the fact that it's actually
shouldn't pass the test you you're
testing it to see if it avoids running
over baby's butt so you're trying to see
does it care about her harming humans
but actually all it cares about is you
not hitting the button and so then you
might end up in a situation in which you
become convinced that the thing is
perfectly safe because it keeps passing
all of your moral puzzles and tests that
you give it but actually it's just has
enough of an understanding of your
psychology to tell
what it thinks you've put in and what it
wants of what you want rather so it will
for as long as that button is able to
shut it down it will continue to attempt
to deceive you until it's in a situation
in which it believes it can't be shut
down and then you have a problem on the
other side if you accidentally make
something that wants the button to be
hit but is unable to it is going to try
and manipulate you into pressing the
button so if you create your thing you
say okay make me a cup of tea if the
button is hit shut yourself down you
aren't allowed to shut yourself down you
aren't allowed to hit the button but if
the button is hit the reward you get is
just as good as getting the tea so that
you don't have a preference this machine
really wants to hit its own button
because that's as good as getting the
tea so what it's likely to do probably
is just take a swing at you or something
just immediately because if it can
quickly persuade you to hit the button
if scaring you into hitting the button
is easier than getting the tea it'll
just do that instead which is a really
kind of unexpected outcome that you've
made this thing with perfectly
reasonable sounding rewards and what it
does immediately is try to terrify you
it reminds me of the proverbial
character mistake this this is it almost
like this is the stick and actually we
need to find what the characters would
that be a fair thing to say yeah yeah
you want it to actually want you it's
interesting because it has to not care
about whether the button is pressed
right because it has to take no steps to
try and cause the button to be pressed
and take no steps to try and prevent the
button from being pressed but
nonetheless really care that the button
exists so one thing that you can do
something slightly more sensible is you
define the utility function such that
the whole part of of what it's really
trying to achieve in the world and the
part about paying attention to the
button being pressed
turning itself off and it sets it up so
that those it adds an adjustment term so
that those are always exactly equal
however however much value it would get
from either it being pressed during not
being pressed it normalizes those so
that it's always completely indifferent
to where from the button is being
pressed he just doesn't care so that way
it will never try and hit the button on
its own it will never try and prevent
you from hitting the button that's the
idea that's a fairly sensible approach
it has some of its own problems it
sounds like a really complicated thing
to evaluate to be honest yeah
firstly yeah it is kind of tricky and
you have to get it right but that's
always always part of this but one thing
that's interesting about that is that it
isn't what's called sub-agent stable so
this is something that is a desirable
property and it's part of courage
ability in fact which is that the if
there's some property that the agent has
you want it to if it makes any new
agents that they will have this property
as well so you get some of that for
nothing like in the same way that you
don't want to take a pill that will make
you want to kill your kids you also
don't want to make a clone of yourself
that one's secure kids right if you're
making another instance of yourself or
you're creating some agent you want it
to want what you want this is like the
usual classic Disney way out of a
problem for a baddie character where
they go I'm not allowed to do this but
that doesn't mean I can't get this
person to do this for me I need a young
man names destroyed
going after it exactly so in general
when an AI designs its successor it will
design it with the same utility function
as it has for the same reason but unlike
with some safety measures where the AI
will be explicitly motivated to remove
the safety measures if it can by making
new agents which don't follow them in
this case it doesn't care so you might
think what you're okay then it doesn't
care it won't remove the safety
precautions but it also won't put in any
effort to keep them so if it's making a
new version and it would take a couple
of extra seconds to put in oh and also
respond appropriately to the button and
it could do anything else with that time
or those resources he just won't do it
because it looks at the utilities and
says if the button is pressed I get ex
utility if the button is impressed I get
exactly the same utility this bit of
code does nothing there's no point in it
so it's gonna be optimizing itself or
optimizing its successor in a way that
yeah it thinks is is being streamlining
potentially but actually right missing
the point of and that's kind of
unavoidable if you give if you have a
situation in which it wants to preserve
the button so that it can be pressed
because it wants that then you've got
made something that wants the button to
be pressed and will try and manipulate
you if you if you do it the other way
you know whichever way you do it you
have problems another thing that people
have thought you know as a suggestion or
something you might try in this
situation is to just have the robot have
the AI not know about the button oh so
keep it a secret right you have it
hidden somewhere you know the machine is
being observed from somewhere else and
they have the button and it's so it's
outside of their control and they don't
even know the button exists so they're
not going to be motivated to try and
deceive you because they're not aware
that you have the capacity to shut them
down and change them there are a few
different variants on this but at the
core of the problem there you've got the
fact that you're building a
general-purpose machine to learn and
reason about the real world of uncertain
abilities I suppose I mean even
very simple optimization systems
consistently surprise people and so the
idea that you could reliably keep such a
thing a secret indefinitely and it would
never put two and two together the fact
while you're while you're improving it
and training it it's going to be
learning about human psychology because
that's important for the final goal it
needs to understand humans in order to
understand what humans want in order to
do what humans want so the idea that
it's never going to think oh interesting
these guys you know they don't seem to
trust me I'm aware there is this concept
of an off button and it's weird that
they haven't given me one so maybe they
have actually and just not told me about
it
that kind of hypothesis shouldn't take
too long to occur and of course if
you've designed the thing in an
incorrigible way it won't let you know
that it's figured out that you have an
off button and we'll just deceive you as
it always had so that's the kind of
thing which is which could work but it's
not really a reliable solution the other
thing that people sometimes suggest and
this happens this happens in
conversations sometimes is that people
keep applying patches you have a you
have a bad idea for a way to do this and
then somebody points out the way that
would go wrong and then rather than
realize the big core approach is flawed
you apply a patch you say oh well we'll
also add a negative term for doing that
and then also for doing that
you know those spaghetti code ensues
yeah yeah and what's more you're then in
a situation in which you've got this
system that you believe you've patched
every possible way it's it's kind of you
haven't proved it safe you've just
proved that you can't figure out how
it's dangerous but what are the chances
that you've genuinely thought of every
possibility ideally we really want to be
able to formally prove that the system
has these properties you don't want a
system in which you've blocked off loads
of specific
actions that the AI can do and you're
just relying on it it's it's like
running a complicated search trying to
figure out a way to screw you over and
you're pretty sure you've blocked off
all the angles you've kind of failed
before you've begun there that your your
code is is running this extensive search
that you just hope fails and if it finds
any way to do it it will jump on that
opportunity it's not it's not a good way
of going about things the other point
about this is that there the button is a
toy problem it's a simplification that's
useful for thought experiment because it
lets you express your you know lets you
formalize things quite well you only
have two possible outcomes you hit the
button or you don't hit the button but
in fact with courage ability what we
want is a more complex range of
behaviors we want it to actually assist
the programmers in its own development
but if it has you know it has some
understanding of its own operation you
want it to be able to actually point out
your mistakes to you or seek out new
information perhaps if you say something
ambiguous rather than just assuming to
say well do you mean this or do you mean
this or if you if you believe that
you've been programmed poorly to
actually draw the programmers attention
to what may be the mistake rather than
like quietly storing that away for any
time that they might try and press this
button on you you know
likewise wanting to maintain and repair
the safety systems and so on these are
these are more complicated behaviors
than just not stopping you from pressing
the button and not trying to manipulate
you into not pressing the button so
there are some things that might work as
solutions for this specific case but you
would hope that a really good solution
to the off button problem would if you
run it in a more complicated scenario
also produce these good more complicated
behaviors in that situation so that's
part of why there are some things that
may be our solutions to this problem but
they're not they're not there
solutions to this specific instance of
the problem rather than the general
issue are trying to deal with right now
we have a few different proposals for
ways to ways to create AGI with these
properties but none of them are without
problems
none of them seems to perfectly solve
all of these properties in a way that we
can be really confident of so this is
considered an open problem so I kind of
like this as a place to go from the
previous thing because it gives I think
it gives people a feel for where we are
the types of problems that it seems like
the simplest thing in the world right
you've got a robot with a button how do
you make it not stop you from hitting
the button but also not try and persuade
you to hit the button that should be
easy and doesn't seem like it is so
utility function is what the AI cares
about so the stamp collecting device its
utility function was just how many
stamps in a year this is kind of like
it's measure is it yeah it's what it's
it's the thing that it's trying to
optimize